[Applause]
live from the headquarters of ramsy
solutions it's the ramsy show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationships I am your host for the day
Jade warshaw joined by Mr Rogers himself
Ken Coleman looking like a finger a
bourbon you look good in brown kin uh
the team likes to call these Cardigans
yes Cardigans instead of Cardigans you
know what I I felt in a fall mood today
I had no idea you were going to show up
looking like the first day of spring so
we are we are quite the couple today
come on give quite the couple a call
give us a call at triple 8825 5225 he's
the work in career guy let's talk about
I am the money girl oh I was I was
wanting to know was it gal or girl I I
could have gone better with that that I
felt I say gal but George makes fun of
me for saying like old words like gal
but I think it fits the cardigan so
let's help some people shall by the way
every serious man needs a cardigan in
his closet I'm telling you that's
debatable okay okay that's debatable
leave that there all right well give us
a call the lines are open but before we
do king Coleman you know I got to get
into this right here here give it to me
let me talk about it this is amazing
first of all congrats our order because
my friend has got a new quick readout
called money's not a math problem let's
see where's the camera there we go I'm
going to put that this is my David
Letterman moment for those of you used
to watch him he would put the forefinger
up there look at her she looks like a
million dollars looks like you feel like
a million dollars uh and it says money's
not a math problem the real reason
you're broke in what to do about it why
should people buy this other than the
fact that you're amazing and it's $10
it's $10 number one so there's no reason
not to buy it but here's the thing how
many times do you guys call into to our
show and say guys I'm I'm doing my
budget but I can't stick to it or I'm I
feel like I'm doing this money stuff but
it's just not working or how do I get my
spouse on board all of these things that
aren't about the numbers Ken it's all
about what takes place upstairs up in
the Noggin what we think about our money
what our belief system is and believe it
or not the things that you believe about
your money drive your behavior with your
money so this is your chance to get into
it I share my own stories in this okay
this is me Examining myself and
hopefully you will see yourself through
that same lens and you'll read it and
you'll be like H Jade yes like this this
is it so get your copy today $10 and if
you pre-order you do get some little
goodies you get a a free Q&A webinar
session with just me oh wow and you get
three months three months free of every
dollar premium which is the creme Dela
creme okay so this is what you guys this
is your homework for today go and
download this book it's perfect for
giftgiving it's the holiday season this
is what you need to get your money right
before January 1 okay 42 pages of force
cuz my friend is a force of nature thank
you and I have one other question what's
up um the earrings did you choose the
back cover the green to match the
earrings there is some validity to that
Ken I I I appreciate that I'm a friend
of fashion yeah for those listening it's
it's this teal the a teal background
with an orange jacket and a strip shirt
like it is bright and colorful it looks
like a magazine lot it's a lot but it's
it's you're a lot and that's a good
thing it is an acquired taste Ken no
you're you're much like your
cardigan well played Ken Coleman all
right let's take a call let's go to the
for phone lines we got Wyatt in
Philadelphia PA what's going
on hey uh Hey guys good to good to talk
to you thanks for taking my call of
course um so yeah I'm so I'm a cabinet
maker uh by trade and uh you know I'm 33
my wife stays at home with our four
little kids and um so I make I make 30
bucks an hour and um I just feel like I
can't can't get ahead financially can't
really seem to save any money I don't
have any debt other than our mortgage
which is around I think we owe we just
bought it like four years ago and
refinanced I think we we still probably
Ow like 200,000 or something on it um
and you know in the Philly area it's
pretty hard to find a house that's any
cheaper than that um we were fortunate
to get this place uh but but anyway I
mean I feel like I you know I cut cost
anywhere I can I heat my house with
firewood that I prepare right you know I
my own cars I right I have no debt no
credit cards no student loans nothing
like that so what is it that you're
trying to what's the specific area where
you're like like I'm trying to
accomplish XYZ but I keep hitting a
roadblock well I just like I can't seem
to build up our savings at all like you
know I we uh you know I put a little bit
of money in my IRA every every paycheck
and my boss matches that graciously um
what kind of margin do you have what
kind of margin do you have when you when
you pay all the bills you take care of
groceries gas you know all the things
what kind of margin do you have at the
end of the month uh yeah I mean probably
like
I'm saying probably a few hundred bucks
maybe 500 bucks does that include does
that include the IRA contribution at
that point or is that not before you
made
that that's that's probably including
that um you know I think it's uh might
be like $2 an hour that I contribute and
then my boss matches that so so four 500
bucks is what's left over so you could
be saving that per month
yes yeah yeah just then maybe I need to
do a better job of budgeting I mean I
don't feel like we're buying a bunch of
extra crap that we don't need though
just well let's make sure I just want to
make sure we're on page on par with the
numbers so you said you make $30 an hour
so what are you bringing home are you
bringing and this is don't don't
subtract anything out of it yet are you
seeing like 4,800 a month is that where
you're at no no about 4,200 and that's
you know after taxes and I work a little
bit overtime okay you know few hours a
week um so it's around yeah around 4200
and how much is the mortgage coming
out it's
1460 I think a month okay so here's
whenever people tell me they're
struggling to get ahead I kind of just
show them big per big number percentages
right I'm like okay your mortgage and
rent shouldn't be any more than 25% so
you got that then you've got 10% should
be going to giving should have about 15%
going towards
steady retirement contribution 15% so
that puts us at 50 right of the things
that are like this is making me fiscally
and financially responsible so my
question to people is what's what is
happening with the other 50% and that's
when you've really got to dial into your
budget do you have an every dollar
budget no I don't have that okay you're
not going to leave this phone call
without every dollar so I want you to go
and download every dollar and I want you
to get the free version
then I want you I'm going to give you a
promo to get $15 off so that you can get
the premium version for a lot cheaper
okay because it's just got more bells
and whistles to make it even easier but
the every dollar free version will get
the job done trust and believe so that
that 50% I'm telling you there's
something in your budget that is eating
your lunch and it's probably it's
probably food a food category a
restaurant category maybe there's a
hobby that you or your wife has that's
eating more into this than what you
realize and I think if you do some
detective work on that other 50% you're
going to find that margin because you've
done well you have no debt your house
feels very reasonable the money is there
I promise you you've just got to do a
little detective work to find it but I
want you to know you're on the right
track just get that investing up to 15%
um when the time comes after you've
saved 3 to 6 months and then you'll be
there this is the ramp show
[Applause]
[Music]
um
hey guys it's Rachel Cruz it's open
enrollment season so it's a great time
to explore your health care options for
next year if you feel tied down by your
budget check out Christian healthc Care
Ministries chm is not health insurance
it's a faith-based health cost sharing
Ministry that has helped members take
care of nearly 10 billion in healthcare
costs chm is an affordable alternative
to insurance that gives you the freedom
and empowers you to live out your values
and you can join at any time so find out
more at chministries.org
[Music]
budget
all right all right you guys are
listening to the ramsy show my name is
Jade warshaw your host today I'm joined
by Ken Coleman my other host for the day
and we're talking about your life your
money and your work the work that you do
should matter it's very important and so
Ken Coleman is here to take any
questions surrounding that I'm going
throw I'm going to throw a little idea
out okay uh if you want to start a
business in 2024 you want to work for
yourself maybe it's a side hustle to get
out of debt or maybe it's just I Want To
Be My Own Boss um if you got an idea and
you want to bounce it off of us today I
just put that out there because we're
seeing more and more of this in our
country today and I think as people
think about this year wrapping up and do
I make moves I'm just going to throw
that out we'll take any work related
question any money question but just
kind of kicking that around this is kind
of shark tank without the rejection yeah
it's perfect because you're the you're
the career work you got your framework
for that and I've I've done it like I've
started businesses from ground up so
let's do let's do that and let's also go
to Emma in Jacksonville FL Rider what's
going on Emma Hi how are you guys doing
today doing good how are you doing good
how can we help so I had a little
situation with uh two car loans that I
have uhuh one my sister was supposed to
take over and then the second one I got
because my car got totaled and then my
sister decided she didn't want the car
anymore so now I'm stuck with both
payments whose name are both cars in are
they both in your name in my name okay
they're both in my name yikes well this
may not be that bad what is and
one like one is on the to being
repossessed I make both PS is that the S
the car that the sister's been driving
or your your car for all intents and
purposes uh the one that I'm driving she
parked the car back at my house so I
have both cars I have possession of both
cars again okay so let's walk through
the numbers on this and figure out how
to get through this so let's call car
number one the car that your sister had
even though it's in your name and we'll
call car number to your car that's also
in your name so car number one what is
that one worth what do you owe want it
and if you were to sell it what do you
think you could get for it based on
Kelly Blue
Book um car number
one I owe
9,000 and it's worth about six okay so
three upside down and is that six based
on Kelly Blue Book personal
sale private sale private sale okay so
3K upside down okay and let's go to the
next one car number two one um so it's
worth
and I owe 29 oo lordy okay um how did
that
happen I was in a pretty desperate
situation my car got total and I needed
a car to get back to work and my sister
she
was completely taking over the car and I
asked her before I bought it like are
you sure you want to take over this car
completely she said yes I love it I need
a car too so I decided to buy a new car
obviously
with a bad interest rate it's about 20%
and I only have $1,000 to put down
because my car just got total I just
bought that car about four months before
that and did you roll negative equity
into it or just no I bought it just aw
lot okay I do want you to check
something I actually learned something
from Dave and you might want to look
into this he he's made it very clear
that sometimes people think that
they have less have more to pay on the
car than what really is because of the
way the bill looks and they're just
showing you your total of payments
they're not really showing you what's
left so just do a little bit more due
diligence and find out for sure is this
the payoff is 29,000 the payoff and just
double check that for me
324 okay so you to double check that
okay now let's get into your numbers and
figure out how to make this work are
these cars your only
debt no okay what other debt do you have
I have student loans for about
30,000 that I just started paying on
after the pause went off okay I
have 12,000 in credit card debt okay 10
in personal
loans
okay and I think and then these two cars
and the two cars okay well I have my
mortgage too but okay let's not talk
about the mortgage that's on the back
earner for quite a while what are you
earning per month what's your take-home
pay what do you see when you get your
check about
70,000 a year okay when when when you
take your check home every two weeks or
every month how much is
it I get I'm a server so I get tips I
don't really get like
a a set amount set amount but so on a
normal month on a normal month I'm
averaging about five 5,000 a month okay
and do you have any kids or is it just
you or you married I have one child and
I'm a single mom so he's five and he's
five in daycare or what do you do with
that um he's in public school okay
kindergarten okay all right you you're
in a Dilly of a pickle I'm not going to
lie I'm going to shoot you straight you
you've got you got some mess on your
hands that needs to be cleaned up and
the first thing I would do I'm guessing
you don't have any money saved
anywhere no I do not I'm kind of
spending all of it just on my debt and
my just trying to just trying to stay
above water yeah um I want you I want
Ken to jump in here because right now we
have a income issue yeah and this is not
going to get cleaned up the way it needs
to be and in the time frame that we
really need this to roll until we can
get more income coming in so I'm about
to uh give him the assist here but the
first thing on your list is getting out
of that car that's
$9,000 and you're going to take that
$3,000 hit some way or another whether
it's you um saving up $3,000 cash and
just making it even or if it's you
running down to the credit union and
saying hey I need a $33,000 loan to get
this $9,000 debt off my back at that
point you're going from a $9,000 debt to
a $3,000 debt so it is still lowering
the process which is what we want to do
but you've got to get out of that out of
at least one of these cars so you don't
have two car payments so that's what you
do first I I actually want to say if it
were me Jade I I want to know what you
think on this I'd get rid of the the uh
the more expensive car first well I want
her to but I don't know that she's going
to be able to get a loan for the amount
you don't think she can get the 13 or
whatever the difference is I because of
just her income and the if you can I
would do that because then she can then
she that next car is in that debt
snowball now she's got a car she can
actually drive but it's a whole lot less
but I mean it's to your point it's I
would just the value in that one is a
little higher so I want to get as much
as I can for that yeah yeah if look Ken
makes a good point if you are able to
get a loan for the difference on car
number two the one that's worth 16 you
can try um and and try hard but I don't
you know I don't want you to get caught
up in some really crappy loan terms so I
really want you working with a small
Credit Union someplace that's going to
have your back I don't want you going to
Sofi you know what I'm saying okay okay
how can we how can we increase your
income quickly and what I mean by that
is what skill and what set of skills and
experience do you have do you go this is
this is what I do best this is my skill
set and I've got experience here because
I want to think about some freelance gig
stuff that could increase your income
quickly what do you have to offer there
well I'm a I'm a waitress like manager
at a restaurant that's in a really
touristy spot so that's why my income
kind of is higher than a lot of service
but I have two degrees I have one in
Psychology and I have one in um pre-law
studies wow H okay so here's what I'm
doing I'm I'm getting online and I'm
going all right um what kind of uh uh
remote after hours work cuz I know
you're waitressing so we got to figure
out okay do I have time in the Daye or I
have some time at night or weekends
where is your block of time that you
could actually do more
work um probably in the nighttime
because I my son to go to school during
the day so here's what I'm thinking
tutoring tutoring is a premium it's
you're sitting there the baby's asleep
you know what I mean you can do it at
your computer um I'm thinking about
tutoring or teaching tutoring is one
thing with that with that law degree or
pre-law or whatever it is uh you know uh
or the
psychology what is some what is some
like uh
online uh extra work I can get where I'm
being paid a premium for my expertise
and it's somewhere in that maybe some
low-level counseling maybe some teaching
or training that's what I'd be looking
for Jade to get in some extra money
quickly absolutely I think people forget
about those night hours that are
available to them to really make some
good money and you've got the ability to
do that and make it known this is the
key to unlocking this problem you need
more money coming in and the only way to
do that is to get more work going out
this is the ramsy
[Music]
[Applause]
show
well you've all played the telephone
game the first person Whispers a message
to the second person who Whispers it to
the third and so on around the table
until the original message has
completely changed multiply that
confusion by a 100 if you run a business
with different software systems that
don't talk to each other that's why
there's netsuite by Oracle in the early
days of ramsy we were using different
systems for all of our business units we
needed one one single source for
accurate data netw Suite was the
software we used to optimize and take us
to the next level net weite gave us the
visibility into all of our numbers so
that we could communicate across
departments and plan ahead better and as
we grew it scaled with us net week
worked for ramsy and it will make a
difference for your business too join
the more than 34,000 customers who trust
netsuite to help make them smarter and
make better decisions and level up their
operations to learn more get a free
product tour at nets.com Ramsey that's
netsuite.com
[Music]
Ramsey
you're listening to the ramsy show I am
Jade warshaw that is Ken Coleman and we
are here taking calls all afternoon
about your money your career your work
your relationships how money is
affecting all of it and how all of it is
affecting your money so give us a call
the number is 8825
5225 Ken I can't believe it's almost
Thanksgiving because just a a little
over a month ago back in October we went
down to DC because it was the beginning
of this whole student loans are coming
back the payments back the interest is
hitting and it is affecting Americans
and so we wanted to get a pulse on
really how this is affecting people on
the streets taking it to the streets
like Michael McDonald said we were able
to interview folks um in DC we went to
the Georgetown area we went all around
getting people's t take on how this
student loan pause and payments coming
back is affecting people so we want to
kind of show you a compilation of what
we
[Music]
heard did you have to get student aid to
come here yes I'm on financial aid got
like a work study job but um yeah yeah
they'll they'll rack up for sure no you
did not Mom and Dad yes wa way to go Mom
and Dad yeah I I came in with a
scholarship from elsewhere so they pay
for all my stuff so you're full ride
yeah full ride up top dude that's what
I'm talking about I do have uh loans for
my graduate school for med school how
much do you have already uh I'm a
freshman I can't remember the per
semester number but it's not it's not
cheap it's like in the thousands yes
it's about like
$350,000 hold on one second I'm going to
have to get down here and breathe I
think I get about like uh 20,000 20,000
and do you know how much of that is aone
uh I believe about half of it half of it
so maybe 40,000 over the four years are
now your parents going to help you pay
that yes are you going to have to pay
any of it back at all um likely not I'm
feel like I'm pretty lucky that my par
are able to help out a lot with that uh
I mean hopefully I'm in in a spot we
kind of share the burden but I mean
realistically we'll we'll see about that
the government has like like kind of
like a program where they calculate um
it's like an income driven repayment
plan honestly uh had opportunity to get
into the income uh driven payment option
so I'm a little ease that it's maybe a
reasonable payment that I can afford uh
however with the interest securing it's
already accured $1,000 in one month
before I even made an actual payment if
you had to guess just if you said you
know what Jade I think it's probably
going to take x amount of years for me
to pay off this debt in full or if you
even plan to pay it off tell me a little
bit about that I mean I'm going to be
completely honest I have no earthly idea
but I mean for the first few years we
going to be on the on the struggle train
a little bit on The Struggle Bus as a
resident I'll probably have like a
payment of about like $200 but like you
know $200 when the total is probably
$400,000 and the interest is still
accumulating and that's only like a drop
in the bucket every year exactly what
does it due to you emotionally to be
thinking about $350,000 worth of
debt it's I mean right now I mean I'm
under so much stress and pressure that I
kind of put it all to the side yeah it's
outside out of mind you're already in
med school and it's pressure enough
exactly I mean going off and finishing
school and kind of like restarting your
life in a lot of ways is so much
pressure on anyone so imagining having
all that debt on your shoulders is just
like an unbelievable extra burden like
you're essentially going to be working
for the next it could be the rest of
your life right to pay that off and like
it's just kind of crazy to expect a
22-year-old to you know have that much
[Music]
foresight
do you think tuition is outsized it's
gotten ridiculous what are your thoughts
on this 100% the government was giving
more loans it it raised the the cap of
the the loans that were available so as
a result a lot of colleges and
universities just increased their
tuition and the people that are paying
the price are the students yeah pretty
absurd even though like someone who's
very lucky like I am just like asking
someone to pay 80k a year it's pretty
ridiculous sus I think it's it's an
unfortunate way to capture people in
debt it's not affordable for most people
they've been allowed to do this forever
it's it's what they do it's what we've
allowed to happen I mean I'm curious
like why has it gone up so much what do
you think about how tuition has gone up
12% a year for the last 10 years what do
you think about that as a student is it
worth it I mean honestly I love going to
school here but like you think about it
once you actually start thinking about
the real money about going here and like
you could get a similar education
obviously at a lot of other universities
and there are a lot of like
opportunities afforded to us here but I
think that for a lot of people whose
parents can't help them as much as I'm
fortunate enough that my parents can
help me going out into the real world
after college and having that much like
debt on your shoulders is just a lot and
I think for a lot of people it might not
be worth it it's obviously not in your
favor at all and you probably like die
still pay and back your Deb you
certainly worth it you think so more so
beyond the academic benefit um but the
value of you know a social
community did you hear about Biden and
the Forgiveness the student loone
forgiveness and then the Supreme Court
shut it down are you familiar with that
yeah what are your thoughts on that
honestly I feel like a lot of things
like that like may appear to be
something good that a politician is
doing but in reality I don't think
anything to that extent would ever go
through just because you know he wants
to seem like he's doing all this stuff
for students for young people but in
reality that's never going to happen I
mean personally I lean pretty left so I
say yeah the government should have a
say in that but I know like some of my
fellow classmates might not think to say
it is the responsibility of students
that take up the loan to repay it back
at some point I know it probably does
suck but you took on the loan and took
on the education hopefully you had a
great plan afterwards to earn enough
income to pay it back I think it's
complete political blasphemy it's
catering
to his a portion of his base and I think
that obviously gained political traction
but I think it's infeasible and for the
people who have paid off their loans I
think it's it's a poor lesson teaching I
think there are people who have busted
their to repay their loans and they're
just off the hook yeah I'm kind of
conflicted in this I believe that people
should be responsible um for you know
for the the deaths they've taken out
sure and they need to be accountable for
that on the other hand my selfish side I
would like student loan forgiveness for
sure honestly um uh as educator I'm
disappointed I was looking forward to
just being able to start new uh fresh uh
looking forward to purchasing my first
home uh so it's definitely it's
disappointing we have a responsibility
to help what's fair what's not fair I
don't I don't have that answer um is it
fair I understand people are like okay
well you forgive mine well you know and
someone else is like whoa I on a while
my take may be that the government
should be the one who fixes this problem
I think again at the Baseline we can all
agree that the problem needs to be fixed
the government we need to do better we
need to do better in this country to
help educate our people yeah the youth
have no idea when they're signing they
don't know what $100,000 is they don't
know what $200,000 is not to mention the
interests yeah I mean you have to be
very smart with your choices and live
within your means and and uh yeah have a
plan to repay it change is going to
happen if we change and say enough no
more our youth our people deserve better
what if I told you that I paid off
$280,000 of debt I would ask you how did
you do it and can you teach me does it
give you hope though does it make you
feel like it can be possible
[Music]
absolutely wow wow wow wow wow look if
you were listening on podcast you need
to head over to the ramsy Show YouTube
and watch that because it's totally
different it's different when you watch
it and uh honestly if you're looking for
more information about this I want you
guys to go to Ramsey solutions.com
studentloans because here's the thing
the new cycle moved on Ken the new cycle
went on and they're talking about I
don't know what they're talking about
again but the pain of this is still
affecting people every single day people
are making payments they're still deeply
deeply in debt and we just want to know
we still see you guys and we're still
here for you and at the end of the day
there's still a way out and there's a
way to avoid them hey real quick we'll
help you get out of it financially but
here's a two-part question is a degree
and the loans that come with it the only
way to get where you want to go or is it
the best way if the answer is no to
either one hey go get you a certificate
go get you a community college associate
degree you can get where you want to go
without the degree many times and by the
way that means no debt so let's think
about that as well love it Ken this is
the Ramsey
[Music]
[Applause]
show if you're like most people your
home is your most valuable asset and
when you want to make improvements it
can feel like everything costs too much
or takes too long but something as
simple as custom window coverings from
blinds.com can completely change your
space and add value to your home we've
recommended blinds.com for over a decade
so you know you can trust them from
blinds drapes and shutters to motorized
Shades they make it easy and affordable
to upgrade your entire home and their
team is ready to help with everything
from design consultation to measuring
and installation plus there are never
any misleading quotes or hidden fees
everything's backed by their 100%
satisfaction guarantee and shipping is
always free Cy blinds.com is the number
one online retailer of custom window
coverings visit blinds.com to save up to
40% off everything sitewide go to
blinds.com for more
[Music]
[Applause]
information what's going on everybody
you are listening to the Ramsay show and
I I don't know about you Ken but I
am shook really shook is the word that
it's wow it's about to be Thanksgiving
okay I was going to ask you what's Got
You All Shook Up I I just feel like this
last last half of the year has gone by
fast we're into Thanksgiving we're
already getting into Christmas which
means here at Ramsey Solutions it's
really really exciting because we do our
$12 Christmas sale every single year and
so I love this sale because you go to
Ramy solutions.com and you can load up
I'm talking about you can load up on
things that should not be $12 that you
can get for $12 and not only that but
they also do like this cash giveaway
thing which is pretty awesome so there's
just a lot going on if you go to ramsy
solutions.com
giveaway you can sign up to win money so
that you can then go spend the money you
know what I'm saying so ramsy
solutions.com away is where you can sign
up to win cash money I'm talking about
$5,000 is what we're giving away
then you turn around take some of that
money and head over to this $12 sale now
I'm not you know I'm not saying rob
Peter to pay Paul I'm just saying this
is a nice little strategy going on it is
and you could get like both of my
best-selling books uh you know that
could help you I mean from payche
purpose helps my kids yes it helps my
kids eat you know these are things that
you know you have to think about Jade
let me tell you what I think is the and
and this is no diss on you king Coleman
this is just a personal thing the fact
that you can get the total money
makeover for $12 really blows my mind
because that book helped my husband and
I pay off
$460,000 so if what you get from it is
any indication of what it's worth then
all I'm saying is the book is really
worth almost half a million dollars I
see what you did there and you're
getting it for $12 okay all right so uh
so the question is um Can people enter
daily to win the $5,000 you can enter
every single day because the thing is
they give away little prizes in between
it like I believe they give away $500
weekly that's right so there's real
money at stake here like this is real
skin in the game right you can enter to
win every day so and no purchase
necessary all those things so uh
ROM yeah you can if you want to do the
giveaway you go to ramseys solutions.com
giveaway that's to get that free money
and then if you're like Jade I got
Christmas shopping then you go over here
to ramsy solutions.com store and get you
some of that $12 holla that's what I'm
talking about all right now I got
something to talk about all right and I
think this is controversial this is this
is exciting I want to know you guys can
get in the comments and you can voice
your opinion on this is it too soon to
start decorating for Christmas no I
don't think so either thank you I'm with
you on this we agree on this one drop it
in the poll are you post Halloween like
the next day do you wait a couple days
I'm going to tell you guys how it's done
right and then we're going to hit these
phone lines this is how it's done boy
right she's confident folks after how
November 1st you keep your fall
decorations out you don't keep Halloween
decorations out Halloween goes away the
day after Halloween you keep your fall
decorations out but you put up your
Christmas trees and you don't even have
to put the ornaments on them yet oh this
like a pre- decoration it's out there
how long maybe a week or two then you
put the you put the or it's it's a it's
a slow fade then you put the ornaments
on the tree so that by the time folks
come to your house for Thanksgiving you
got the trees out but but it still got a
fall Vibe then after Thanksgiving you
put take the fall decorations down and
put out the rest of your Christmas
decorations that's the proper way to do
it I don't know I don't know I wanted to
agree I don't like to disagree with you
because I like you so much but I'll be
honest with you I think once we go
Christmas we got to
go go half fall half merry jingle it's
got to be one or the other so you go all
the way I think so look I want I spend
money on these decorations I want them
to get their full umph okay cuz this
this people watching on video to uh make
sure they see my dark brown cardigan
that you said I looked like look this
time I'm going go for two fingers of
bourbon Ken the coolest thing anybody's
ever said about they see all the Browns
you got like I know all of it I do so
there you go Ken let's take a call for
crying out loud let's go to Kin in
Houston Texas what's going on Karen is
it Karin did I say it right hi yes ma'am
yeah you did nice Hooked on Phonics Big
Bird what's going on Karen
so I have
$20,000 that I want to like create
passive income and uh with and so like
my my few options I was thinking like an
ATM you know you have to buy those new
it's a couple thousand and that would
create monthly income or even like
aunder mat but that's obviously it's
talking a lot more money and I don't
have the income to mess around with that
but if I start with something small
like an ATM then I can create passive
stuff but then I also have like a little
bit of debt that I kind of want to put
the money towards but then I also feel
like maybe some can hold off and so it's
kind of a tossup all right so before we
get into the income we got to figure out
what your financial picture is really
quick so layers here yeah how much debt
do you
have so I have $3,200 on a Capital One
credit card and it is like $80 a month
in interest which I I don't I that's
that's bothering me so that's definitely
a priority like the top priority I have
okay keep going sorry what else you got
no so um so I've got it I have two
vehicles one is completely paid off okay
um and then the other one they're both
older I work at a repair shop so I I'm
you know I'm I'm you know have a little
experience with the you know I take care
of my stuff for the most part so um
doesn't have much issues for that one
but then I have a a older one I just
bought and I my dad helped me out was
long story but he lended me five grand
to get this vehicle so I do owe five on
my other car but I'm able to take out
money monthly to pay that off to for him
so I have time on that so it's the 3200
on the credit card five can of car
anything else anything um student loans
no okay no all right so I mean look
there's no passive income strategy until
you pay the debt off that's what we
teach and then we want to make sure that
you got your emergency fund in place
yeah okay do do you know what he's
talking about when he says your
emergency
fund yes the the $1,000 dollar depending
on your income I watched a few of the
Dave Ramsey videos so do you have ,000
1200 yes I have I have closer to like
2,300 or maybe a little bit more but I
was putting that more towards like the
the vehicle um but I I've been taking
that out monthly out of my paycheck so
that's kind like extra I guess my backup
okay let's clean it up a little bit I
like what you're I like what I like the
way your mind is working I just want to
tidy it up a little bit so there's a
2300 that you have set aside as kind of
an emergency fund then You' got an
additional 20,000 that you're hoping to
use to spend money to make money right
so let's take the 23,000 or 2,300 I'm
sorry let's back that down and I'm just
going to walk through this this this is
all going to happen basically in one day
but I'm walking you through it so you
can see what the process is all right in
one day you're going to imagine that
2,300 going down to 1,000 and that
essentially is baby step one okay
getting a $1,000 saved and with that
$1,300 that's left you're going to put
that towards the car the $5,000 I'm
sorry you're going to put that towards
your credit card today yeah yeah and
then that's going to leave you what $900
uh 2,000 $1,900 left you're going to
take I'm sorry math is not my thing big
number you're going to take that money
and throw it at that credit card then
you're going to dip into that 20,000
that I know you're like Jade is passive
income but trust me on this just go with
me for a second and if you have
questions at the end we'll get to it
you're going to dip into that 20,000 and
you're going to pay off the rest of that
credit card then you're going to dip
into that 20,000 again and you're going
to pay your dad back fully and you're
going to be fully out of debt and you're
probably going to still have 14 13,000
left all right that's that's your money
131 and then you're going to take that
13,000 and you're going to put it with
the 1,000 that you had before in your
baby step one and now you're going to
have 14, $100 and we're going to use
that to be our three this is baby step
three that we're now on our 3 to 6 Monon
emergency fund because here's here and
here's why I'm saying all this because
right now you're going well Jade you
just spent my 20,000 but here's the
thing I want you on the firm I am all
pro business pro making your money Pro
doing your thing but you've got to have
that foundation in order because when
you have that girl everything after that
everything hits right and it clears your
mind to make better decisions you you
trust me just go with me on this well
and and no and and honestly that's what
I wanted to do I wanted to pay off all
the debt and I wanted to have Savings in
case I need to move or something like
that and have it set but then like I
also felt like almost like that was like
I felt guilty because like I'm not
making more money no you're being smart
you're being smart you're being smart
and if you do this you're going to save
up some more money in no time to make
you more money so do what I just told
you and you are going to be on the right
track that does it for this hour of the
show thanks for listening hang with us
next hour this is the ramsy
[Music]
show
live from the headquarters of ramsy
solutions it's the ramsy show where we
help people build wealth hope you do
work that you love and will help you
create actual amazing relationships I am
Jade warshaw I'm joined by my co-host
bestselling author host of the Ken
Coleman show the man himself Ken Coleman
and we will be taking calls all
afternoon about your life your money
your career your work your relationships
and how they all work together how they
all affect each other um Ken had a great
idea if you're interested in starting
your own business coming up in the new
year you got some ideas call us up run
it past us we'll we'll be a little shark
tank for you and see if it makes sense
we'll poke holes in it give you some
constructive feedback we'd love to do
that give us a call the number is
8825 5225 and we will take your call
matter of fact we're going to see Makita
she's from Asheville North Carolina
what's going on Makita how can we
help hey how are you thank you for
taking my call no problem did I get your
name
right yes he did ah winning yes how can
we
help
my husband and I have a small dog
grooming business um we currently have a
lease at a location and I am not on the
lease um we're looking at a different
location so we can expand our business
and they would like me to be on the
lease and the issue is I do not dog room
I do all the office work you know all of
that behind the scenes stuff but um if
something were to happen to him say he
passes away
I would still be on the lease and I I
don't know the legalities of it um if I
would be responsible for the remainder
of the lease I would say so if I'm
signing it I'm just trying to get some
advice on what to do because we really
want to go to this other location and
expand our business and leases don't
come up very often um but it's just a
big concern does is so is your husband
uh the other name that they're asking to
be on the
lease yes you what what's his does he
have the same concern that you
have um well he he if I passed away he
would be okay because he still does the
dog grooming he would just have to
figure out the rest of you know paying
bills and all the other stuff I do yeah
I mean first thing I'm just going to
Common Sense this one I think there's
two things I would be looking at uh one
if you're concerned about this and I
think it's a valid concern I think you
talked to the landlord about it you know
and and there's a reason why they want
two names on the lease right and then
there's a reason you have a concern on
this I I would have a good old
face-to-face conversation look him in
the eye and go hey uh how would you
treat that you know uh because if if
something happens to him I I don't have
a business because I can't do dog
grooming I I I would start with that
okay the second thing I would do is is I
would also ask your husband if he's done
any work in this but is there any kind
of insurance uh that the business could
take out on on him uh so that you could
take care of things like this lease but
but but I would you know if I was
getting in a situation like that I'd
start with the face-to-face conversation
and go hey I've got a concern about this
obviously this is the only exception
here I have no problem signing up for
this based on any other reasons how do
you feel about it they go well I've got
my reasons they're going to walk you
through this there's a reason why they
have it maybe they make an exception but
I would also look at potentially the
insurance policy um on your husband
through the business and probably not
very very expensive and that would take
care of that type of you know legality
but I would just dive into it and look
at what your options
are okay because I did ask him if they'd
put in like a clause a death and
disability clause for him in the leas
that we could sign and they said no well
okay my take on it is slightly different
um I as a like if I'm a co- business
owner with my husband I kind of would
want my name to be on everything because
I want to know that I have full
ownership the same way he does and the
same amount of skin in the game what the
way my brain is working on this is you
guys have this business if the business
is healthy I would just make sure the
business has a certain number of months
of retained earnings for down months for
if the worst happens and in my mind this
is this is just Jade speaking now if
something God forbid were to happen to
your husband he's the one who knows
grooming he's the one who knows that
what would just happen if you hired
another groomer and kept the business
going
um or you guys worked on my my guess is
that the idea is to keep building this
business and maybe in a year or so or
whatever you do have more than just one
groomer and he's kind of going on there
I just feel like there's a way to keep
this thing going um without does that
make
sense yeah that makes
sense I mean do you want that do you
want that hassle I mean that's the whole
point of your question I mean I don't
mind the advice um I mean I kind of like
your angle
probably I'll go with
Jade yeah honestly I yeah what about the
retain I'll go with you on the retained
earnings you have that set aside so
you've got the the how how long is the
lease that insurance policy it's six
years it's a six year lease all right so
you got you know I mean that's Jade
makes a very good point you guys are
taking out money and you try to get to a
point where that lease you'd be able to
pay it off cash and walk away uh but if
you don't want to keep the business
going if that would be a hassle for you
we're talking worst case scenario here
this is such a worst case scenario and
my bigger question is I guess part of my
question is do you are you not
interested in dog grooming as a business
you just like bookkeeping and da d da d
da cuz in that part at that point it's
kind of like you're I guess you really
are viewing yourself more as like I just
work for this business it's not really
my business like is that kind of where
you're
at like I love the dogs and everything
but the actual art of dog grooming is
very complicated I there's no way my
brain just doesn't like that um well I
mean I get that she doesn't want to be a
dog groomer but my question is long term
if he wasn't the groomer if she's is she
interested in keeping the business going
and just hiring another groomer so
what's the
answer the so the only issue is cuz
we're in a small town is is um because
we've seen another business go through
that they've been through attempting
they've had I think five different
groomers in a year trying to get
somebody in getting them in they leave
it's just we're in a an area that's
really expensive to live in you don't
want to do it it's as obvious as it can
be it's it's yeah then if if you don't
want to do it and we you know playing
worst case scenario then I mean yeah I
would look into the insurance yeah I I
know that that
tires I'm Nott it so could you uh
details it but if it were me I'd be call
my insurance agency I'm assuming you
guys have some type of insurance on the
business anyway and I'm going look what
what can we do here I never even thought
that that's like a great idea because
I'm wearing a cardigan I'm feeling extra
safe today yeah yeah there's cous yeah
I'm just curious I would definitely be
curious to look into that cuz then the
other part of me is like okay like if
she's listed as an owner then maybe
that's why they're requiring it but if
she's not listed as an owner I'm fine as
long as she's got insurance and she's
not responsible for the lease that's all
we want to take care of cuz she didn't
want to do this business yeah that's
interesting I wonder what she would want
to do if the worst were to these
conversations man they're dark and
twisty I'm not going to lie it's like
you want to do it is a whole other
segment but that's what we're talking
about guys that's about to do it for
this segment be sure to give us a call
think about where your question is and
give us a call atle A 825 5225 and we
will be here to chop it up with you this
is the ramsy
[Music]
show hey folks you know that sinking
feeling when you make an offer on a
house you love and then you hear there's
another offer you need the Churchill
Mortgage home buyer Edge super fast
pre-approval and a secured interest rate
plus a $5,000 seller guarantee gives
your offer the best chance of being
accepted the home buyer Edge from
Churchill gives you an advantage over
those other guys go to Churchill
mortgage.com today to learn
[Music]
more
all right you guys are listening to the
Ramsay show I am Jade warshaw he is Ken
Coleman and hey if you like this show if
you've been listening for a while or
maybe you just discovered us I would
love love love love love if you took a
moment to share the show tell somebody
about it and you can do that in a lot of
different ways uh you can text your
favorite episode you can use a little
paper airplane button and you know send
them your favorite clip that we might
post or you can just go in there simply
and like the like it subscribe it
whatever that is that helps us so much
it's totally free it's easy for you to
do and it's really just a way for you
guys to show uh your support and we
appreciate it look we recognize that
without you guys there's not a show so
we thank you for tuning in we really
really hope that this uh resource is
helpful for you right so thank you thank
you thank you so much thank you um
there's a lot going on and uh I want to
talk about this right quick Ken um a lot
of you may have heard that
mint right the the budgeting app mint
that we've all known about is closing
its doors right into it is the big
conglomerate that owns mint and a lot of
people were using mint to do their
budget and now mint has said well we're
closing our doors and a lot of people
are looking out here for a new budgeting
home enter Ramsay
Solutions where's the trumpet sound
effect there there it is there it is
that's great so mint currently has 4
million budgeters Ken that's a lot of
folks and they're just telling 4 million
people hey we're done see you and not
only that then they were like well let
us give you someplace to go why don't
you sign up to Credit Karma so they're
literally K pushing these budgeters into
a platform that's not a budgeting
platform it's really just a place for
them to get into more de venus fly trap
it's a venus fly trap and so you know
I'll be let me just be flat out honest
when I very first started budgeting and
looking for cuz back in the I was on pen
and paper Sam and I getting out of debt
and I remember a hipster buddy of mine
was like hey you should try mint bro and
I was like okay so I went on to try mint
and I was like this is not for me and it
wasn't and then in my search for mint I
saw every dollar and I started using
every dollar from day one oh okay all
right and back let me tell you back in
the day what however many years ago you
know it didn't have the bells and
whistles that it has now and so now
every dollar is Sleek I mean it's a
Lambo it it does all the things that you
need it to do and I just really want to
formally invite anybody listening if
you're looking for a new budgeting home
cuz come January 1st is going to be a
cold day and you're going to need
somewhere to go inside and warm up your
money you know what I'm saying so go
over to every dollar it's it's free you
can download the app for free and you
can get started budgeting for free and
it works like a charm for free there's
also a premium version if you want to do
a little upgrade and get just some more
budgeting features that are going to
help you even more make even more
streamlined some people like that
Hands-On approach though that they get
with the free version where they can
really be Hands-On and other people they
kind of want to be like Jade I need it
to do a little bit more for me and if
that's you that's fine we've got a
premium version it's really cheap uh
really inexpensive for you to use that
one as well um and I know there's a lot
of folks out there that are like Jade
you know what I'mma just I'm going take
this as my cue to do Exel or do pen and
paper mhm but there's a problem with pen
and paper Ken there's a lot of problems
with Excel and pen and paper and part of
it is it's not keeping track in real
time in real are you telling me that you
take your computer with you when you go
into Publix and every time you make a
purchase you're adding it up in your EXL
spreadsheet no what most of y'all do is
at the end of the month you're like well
the month is over let me go reconcile my
budget and you pull out that old 80s
calculator with the tape roll and you
start doing your math and you realize
wow I just went over budget $500 in the
month is it's already over there's
nothing you can do about it now you
already went over budget it's after the
fact what would happen if you had a
budget like every dollar that was on
your phone not just your phone it's on
your phone and your spouse's phone and
in every single day you're getting
update on how much money is actually
there those transactions are
automatically going into the app
automatically updating so you can
automatically see when you get to the
grocery store line hey I only have $179
left to spend well I think can that it
would change the way that you spend
which would ultimately affect your
budget that's correct so I'm just saying
every doar away if you're looking for a
place we want you to come to every
dollar matter of fact I have a promo
code let me just throw that out there if
you go to Every
dollar.com Jade I will I myself will
spend Dave's money and give you $15 off
your first year that's on me or let me
do you one better now this is a little
bit of a roundabout road but let me do
you one better if you purchase pre on
pre order my book which is money is not
a math problem which is truly truly at
its core about budgeting if you purchase
this on pre-order I will give you three
months of every dollar free every dollar
premium I'm talking about the one with
all the bells and whistles that comes as
a perk it's $10 so if you want to get 3
months for free to see how this thing is
really working go ahead and do the book
and that's another little roundabout way
to get this so there's there's methods
Ken there's layers to this thing is what
I'm saying well said well said indeed
anything to add uh no I I think that was
perfect all right let's move on let's
move on we got Rachel and I'm GNA say la
Lafayette lared is Lafayette yes that's
his actual name Louisiana for the
history Buffs out there the man's name
was Marquee de Lafayette and everybody
goes
Lafayette it's like it's not Lafayette
it's Lafayette thank you very much well
this is Rachel and she can tell us if
we're right or not are we right is it
Lafayette it's Lafayette yes okay that's
what I'm talking about what's going on
Rachel how can we help yes hi um I have
a question regarding an investment
property that both my husband and I
own um we purchased it using um an
inheritance um with the intentions of
using the profits to help supplement our
retirement later on and also our
children's secondary education okay um
we paid cash for it two and a half years
ago wow and we currently have um 95,000
invested into it um we currently profit
750 per month after all of our
expenses the kicker is a few days ago we
had our annual HOA meeting where the
annual budget for the complex was
discussed um needed future projects
difficulties collecting HOA fees from
several of the owners
yeah um we also learned that the current
HOA fees are not meeting the current
budget needs and are also not taking
into consider oh excuse me the
consideration for the needed Improvement
projects okay um therefore we're
anticipating a rise in the HOA fees next
year from what to what we just have um
we're not sure about next year but we
just went from 206 to 263 a month in HOA
fees and if you had to guess what do you
think it could get to like what's your
biggest fear I would say I would say
like 350 okay if not more um so where
does that
put what what what's that in our profit
what would that put well no I mean you
call because this is creating a problem
for you so what what what is this making
you consider this raising
HOA um just with no and all the issues
that they're having I'm wanting to sell
my husband's wanting to keep
it so real numbers what are you afraid
of if it goes up as high as 350 what
does that do to your profit margins
aren't you passing some of that along to
your renters if not yeah we are going to
go up on our um on the rent as you
should but I'm afraid yeah I'm afraid
that if we get into the 400s a month
more people in our
units are not going to pay the HOA fees
and then it's just going to go downhill
from there maybe with you
know increase can I just cut in and I I
think that you're I think you're
projecting a lot of what ifs um uh cuz
right now like you said okay it's gone
up 60 bucks that's substantial um but
you're going to pass 30 of it over to
your folks and you're going to take some
of it instead of making 7 750 a month
you're going to make 720 a month and I
would really cross that bridge when you
get to it I think that to just go oh
this is getting crazy I'm selling right
away I mean what would happen if you
just stuck in a little bit longer to
really see where this
goes that's what I would do I mean Ken
yeah I agree I think I think you uh
trust your husband on this walk through
the numbers walk through your fears
let's get some facts on this and let's
move forward I I wouldn't get out
because of Verizon ho this is the Ramsey
Show
[Music]
hey if you're in over your head with
student loans and tired of getting calls
from collection agencies if private
student loan debt is taking away your
financial piece and you don't see any
way out you need why refi they're not a
debt settlement company and they're not
connected to a bank why refi refinances
defaulted private student loans that
other places won't touch and gives you a
custom loan built for you based on your
ability to pay so when you refinance
your private student loan debt with Y
refi you'll have a payment you can
afford with a low fixed interest rate
you couldn't get anywhere else to help
you stick to your budget and work the
debt snowball and you can save thousands
of dollars to learn more about this
custom refinancing option and a lumps
some payoff option you could qualify for
after 24 months call
8442 Ramsey or go to Y rei.com
[Music]
Ramsey
you're listening to the Ramsey Show I'm
Jade warshaw your host joined by Ken
Coleman who is also your host and we are
taking calls all afternoon about your
life and what's going on with your money
and how it relates to the other areas of
your life so if you want to talk with us
give us a call the number is8
825-5222 and we would love to talk with
you we're going to go straight to the
phone to Dennis who's in charlot North
Carolina how can we help today
Dennis Hi how are you Miss Jade I'm
doing good how are you Dennis I'm doing
great I'm super glad to be on here
awesome I'm happy to talk to you what's
going on well it's a little bit about my
situation my mama I'm 18 years old she
passed away last September at the age of
36 due to a drunk driver oh gosh and
since then I moved in with my pastor and
my best friend and I've been having
trouble getting a job my buddy and his
other buddy started construction and
I've worked with off and on but I I get
to start my first day at UPS tomorrow
morning shift 4 a. to 900 P p.m. I'm
looking really much forward to it great
hours good money $21 an hour okay just
to start out but I got a little bit of a
trouble I've been not doing money like I
should I got a credit card very stupid
very stupid and I I'm not it's not due
or nothing but I've already spent 110 on
that credit card my limit is 300 I don't
want to go I don't want to spend any
more on it okay and I my papa is helping
me out because I've had a rough couple
weeks he gave me some money and my
friends when we go out to eat I'll say
no I'm not going to eat I don't have to
they'll pay for it because I got really
good friends and I make sure I put their
money how much I owe them back down so
I'm in debt to friends and credit card
to around $34 something dollars probably
and I'm three days past doing my phone
bill which is $120 and I'm two days past
doing my car insurance which is
$200 okay I got it all written
down okay and you got Zer but you start
the UPS job tomorrow yes and when do you
get your first
paycheck so today was orientation for 10
minutes tomorrow we go in for three
hours at four o'clock but then Friday I
go in four o'clock in the morning so 9
o'clock in the morning my actual hour
first day but I will get that money next
Thursday but it won't be enough I'll get
next week's paycheck after Thanksgiving
okay so after Thanksgiving assuming now
that you've gotten two paychecks how
much money will you have because it's
still the month of November so it's not
like we've crossed into another month
how much money will you have once you
get those two checks after
Thanksgiving I would want to say $600
maybe seven and you've got you've got
shelter you've got a car like you know
what I'm saying you're living with your
pastor and your paa so you've got so
Pastor my best friend pastor and best
friend okay so with that $600 if you
took that and you paid the $200 in car
insurance that leaves you with 400 you
paid the 120 on the phone and then you
paid the credit card for
110 what about that and then with your
next check you came in and you paid the
230 sorry I didn't get to write down
what the 230 was for but whatever that
that's your biggest debt and you paid
that one final how would that feel yes
and then by Christmas time you have no
more
debt be perfect but there's one I got
asked what should which I think it's a
pretty good question because the car is
essential my car insurance will not be
extended should I just let my phone go
off for about a week or so so your car
insurance is late when will they when
would they lapse it they won't lapse it
until the next month right it's just
late at this point they say they send
you a letter out the first day you don't
pay it they'll send you a letter out
saying it's been canceled I talk to on
the phone that's not sure you have like
three days after Okay so let's make that
final that let's make that first
priority because you need to be able to
drive and you need to have insurance so
let's let let that be the first thing
and if for some reason if you're not
able to cover that and it they do laps
it like call them up and be like hey I
just got this job is there any way you
can extend it what will that look like
if they won't then you're just going to
have to pop into another policy and
until you can just don't drive your car
like do not drive around without
insurance and you're going to need
you're going to need somebody in your
circle one of these friends who's been
spotting you some money you know get
them to drive you to work until you can
get this money and get back with your
insurance yes ma'am you got that Ken
Coleman's gonna help you with this
career side come on I'm just really
curious uh you're only 18 you're very
very young and you got plenty of time so
this is not a pressure question I'm just
kind of curious I'm glad by the way
you're at UPS I think this is a great
landing spot for you with all the trauma
you've gone through losing your mom
you're going to get great benefits there
work your butt off just get stable get
your financial feet you know underneath
of you and heal emotionally uh but I am
curious what are you thinking about what
are you wondering about as an
18-year-old young guy about your
professional
future I just well I'm a preacher you
know so I think about preaching a lot
but I want to be successful I'm actually
in the course of taking online real
estate classes right now um so that's a
main thing for me is pursuing real
estate but I want to their classes are
hard they're online and they're they're
difficult but I'm not a quitter that's
really what I do want to do and I'm not
even sure if that's still I want to do a
lot of things right that's fine so are
you thinking bivocational you're selling
homes during the week and preaching on
the weekend is that what I'm hearing yes
sir all right all right well you've got
plenty of time I I I would say this I
want you to walk our baby steps out okay
we got our we got our crisis situation
which really isn't a crisis because you
have a place to land you have a place to
sleep you got food um and let me just
say this on the cell phone thing cell
phone people aren't going to cancel your
cell phone because you're a couple weeks
late no I love the fact that you're
communicating with people and just tell
them exactly your situation look here's
here here's where I'm at I'm okay I got
a great job at UPS it's one of the most
respected companies in the world you're
good to go uh so so then get that $1,000
once we get through this getting caught
up on everything $1,000 in your savings
account that's your emergency fund right
and you have no other debt correct
that's just these small little things
great so here's the deal cut the credit
card up today you don't need you don't
need the credit card that credit card if
you still have it open it becomes an
option for you when times get tough and
it just keeps putting you behind the
eightball and as tough as your life has
been uh over the last year um you can
handle it you have got a a spunk about
you a light that I can just feel coming
through the phone and and there's no
stopping you and you've got support
through the friends through the place to
stay so you don't even need the credit
card for what most people think they
need it for so cut it up and not just
cut it up I'm going to challenge you
when this call is done the next phone
call you make to the credit card company
and cancel it and then once you've got
$1,000 in your savings account baby step
one since you have no debt you are now
moving right into what does a six-month
emergency fund look like for you because
you have no other expenses I like to see
a six-month emergency fund for you but
three to six months will work and now
you begin to go into baby step 4 where
you begin to invest 15% of your income
you're probably going to have a great
retirement count uh set up with UPS get
familiar with it with HR talk to them
about it do your max contribution and
then go go go and and young man uh
you're going to be way ahead of most 18y
olds financially which gives you a ton
of Freedom professionally as you begin
to explore things you understand what
I'm saying yes sir I do and you got my
word I'll cut it up as soon as I get off
here and I'll call them I like it I love
that I love that and just just to get
you started I'd love to give you uh a
couple of months of every dollar premium
so Austin's going to pick up make sure
you get started with the best budgeting
app that is out there I would love for
you to have that and matter of fact you
know what Dennis is on point let's give
him Financial Peace University because I
want him knowing all the ins and outs I
want him completely
Financial literate there we go can I say
it and let's add on to the gifts Austin
let's also give him the get clear career
assessment for him to just begin to
think through what ises my future look
like give him the book from paycheck to
purpose which is also the companion and
uh is there any and you know what give
one of my books waiting for this look I
forgot that I had it to give away let's
be honest about that this is brand new
it's a rookie move it's a rookie move
it's rookie mistake yes give him money's
not a math problem I love it man Dennis
he he's what I call he's what I call a
superstar a stud really great spirit for
a young man who's been through a kind of
a bone crushing Spirit crushing loss 100
Los mama at 36 yeah wow I mean that's
tough stuff what a bright Soul he is but
I really like that he um I really like
that he's surrounded
by really great friends really great
family a pastor a church like people who
really came in and and it sounds like
they just put their arms around him and
made sure that he he knew he was God
like he knew those people had him and I
love that that's I mean you can't that's
what it's all about I love that and I
love the generosity Ken you came through
with you were like Santa Claus I have
the spiritual gift of giving away Dave's
resources something come with oo love it
here to help people I love it it gives
me chills this is the ramsy
[Music]
show
[Applause]
you're listening to the Ramsay show I'm
Jade warshaw this is Ken Coleman to my
right we're taking calls about your life
and your money so give us a call the
number is
8825 5225 we've had a lot to discuss uh
over the past several segments Ken and I
don't know like if you guys listen
regularly uh you may have listened
yesterday and we had a gentleman call in
let me just give you a brief synopsis we
had a guy call in and um he was a uh a
vet who was fully disabled and but he
was still able to work okay and so he
had the GI Bill available to him to pay
for some extended school and because of
the nature of his disability he had I
believe up to
$65,000 of federal student loan
forgiveness available to him even though
he only had $110,000 I needed to be
forgiven so he was trying to ask us
would it be right for him to basically
take out a student loan that would not
be used for Education because he
technically didn't need it but that he
could just use for life like his
mortgage and things like that and we
felt like there was a bit of an e
ethical dilemma there and so we advised
him yeah don't don't take out the money
you can live you can work work I know
it's available but it's for student
loans and in this case you wouldn't be
using it for your education but during
the break Ken and I talked and I thought
I was like you know what this is tax
dollars I'd be willing to give him my
portion which is like
0.019% and it kind of just grew and so
we came back and we asked you the people
well what was my opinion go ahead and
tell them Ken you said I would get I
said I'm not giving him mine I'm like no
you went Scrooge mode no I just went I
just I just went personal responsibility
mode I'm not mad at that which gets
called Scrooge no I'm not mad at you Ken
I get it so then you said let's ask the
people and so James apparently how did
we do this we took a you can drop a poll
on YouTube so we did a YouTube poll and
we got a lot of strong feedback in the
comments as well I'll tell you what the
numbers were and then you can guess
which answer goes with which number all
right okay it was 67% to
32% uh I'm telling you right now the
ramsy audience 67% went with Ken I think
I think you're right I think I lo I
think even though I was like Michael
McDonald and taking it to the streets
nobody cared yeah it was 67% now D it
meaning they agree with me meaning yes
that no that they wouldn't give their
money so they these are people who
believe in rugged individualism personal
responsibility good on you folks I'm not
mad I am not mad because honestly
because because of you guys I am now
011119 which richer okay so thank you
for giving me money back into my pocket
love it this is why I love this show Ken
must hards I do like the poll and I I
like doing this more often I wish we
could uh maybe do a text in and do live
poll results during the show on certain
issues when you are fearless leader
think it might be interesting we should
figure out a way to do that I love that
you want to drop your personal cell
phone number in the chat no but they got
this ability to do this now these people
these these tech people you give out a
text number and then boom I just think
it'd be great all right stay tuned you
never know what can happen we here for
the people so they should have a voice
they do have a voice I'm about to let
let us hear Cheryl's voice right and
Reno and reeno look Ken you got me
flustered Reno Nevada I was thinking
about how I was going to make fun of you
next yeah I was like I was going to say
Ken if you would stop yapping I can go
to Cheryl and hear her voice okay and
then I messed up and said Reno and then
you made fun of me instead Happ that's
what happens what what's going on Cheryl
how can we
help hi thanks for taking my call my
husband just retired the end of June and
we're still trying to get our retirement
budget together but my kids keep
thinking we've got all this money that
we can spend on them and I feel so broke
constantly even though we're not really
giving them money they've got Trust
funds that my parents set up for them
when my parents passed away and I just
don't know what to do anymore so Cheryl
these trust fund kids are hounding you
for money yes and you're but you're not
giving it to them I no but you feel bad
because you're not giving it to
them yes well I thought you said you
feel broke and I'm confused how you
would feel broke because of them I think
you feel broke because of you
all no
okay we have we have more money than
what we're telling the kids we have then
how can you feel
broke because I'm constantly being told
we need money for this we need money for
this we need money for this so I mean
it's getting to be Christmas my daughter
wants Christmas money she how old your
us to cosign for a loan for my
17-year-old granddaughter
a
2020 car because my daughter's credit is
down the to and you want to know whose
problem that
is not my daughter's problem yeah it's
not your problem Cheryl these I'm just
this is your family and you love them
but I am an an impartial person out here
and I'm telling you these folks are
entitled you have done the right thing
you have said no I'm not going to fund
this and that and I'm certainly not
going to do it at your whim if you feel
the need to be generous you can choose
when and how you'd like to be generous
for your family but they do not get to
treat you like Grandma ATM and come to
you whenever they feel like they need
this or that you are exactly right and
if I were in your shoes I would not feel
bad about that for a hot second uh
Cheryl what's the stat wish well okay
we'll come back to that what's the
status of the trust funds are they do
they already have access to them or are
they waiting to get access to them I
have I'm the only one that has access to
them right now my son inherited uh my
parents house as part of his trust we
ended up having to take a loan against
that trust because they would not upkeep
the house and the city has an ordinance
where you can't have just weeds all over
your front yard uhuh so son we ended up
having to take aone against the trust to
pay someone to come out and Landscape
their front
yard car for the granddaughter is a loan
against my my daughter's trust why are
they Lo wasn't about to cosign because I
don't want to make car payments right
okay but my question is does the trust
say is is the trust delineating when and
when certain amounts are supposed to be
distributed to them and they're just not
getting what they felt felt like they
were supposed to or is it something
different the trust gives my
daughter uh $1,500 a month and that's it
and she gets that and she gets that
every month and she wants above and
beyond that is that what you're telling
me and she wants above and beyond that
all right so let me let me my son has a
house to live in right now his rent is
$275 a month to help pay for the sewer
the insurance the property taxes that
type of thing all right Cheryl here's
the problem um your kids know about the
trust and they have known about the
trust for a while enough to let their
behavior be so immature and so lazy that
they can't even cut their own grass and
you've got to take a loan first of all
you didn't have to do any of this you've
done it I think you called today because
you're at your wits end and should be
and you should be but I will
say um you have a lot of responsibility
here and I'm not saying this to be mean
to you at all I'm saying that now is the
day for you to say enough is enough and
you got to decide what you're going to
do here on this trust um I don't think
they've earned it and uh but I I don't
want to get into the minutia of this but
uh because I don't think that that
distracts from from what you need to do
what you need to do is say this is what
you
get and and if it were me I'd change the
the trust to where they don't get any of
it till they show themselves worthy and
responsible of it but uh at this point
they get what they get from the trust
and you need to say that's it that's it
and there's no more asking Mama for
anything which means you are going to
say no to all these loans against the
this is this is this is over and this is
a family meeting wow a come to Jesus
meeting where you make it really really
clear how things are going to be going
forward because these kids are
manipulating you emotionally you sound
like an emotionally weary lady who
actually needs to take charge and let
the kids gripe and complain it's time
for them to be adults I know that's not
fun to hear but this isn't going to
change until you cut them off and be
okay with cutting them off show you're
right Ken I am not going to argue with
that that is strong advice from Ken
Coleman and I agree 100% thanks for
hanging us with with us this hour be
sure to join us next hour on the ramsy
[Music]
[Applause]
show
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsy
solutions it's the Ramsay show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationships I am Jade warshaw I am
joined today by Ken Coleman I am the
money personnel and Ken Coleman is the
work in career personnel but we dible
and Dabble you know into a bunch of
other things so if you want to give us a
call we'll talk about what you want to
talk about as long as it has something
to do with your life your money your
work and your relationships the number
is 8825 5225 the phone lines are open
but I see we've already got David in San
Antonio Texas David what's going on in
your world
dude I have a quick short
question would you recommend a person
who suffers from emotional spontaneous
shopping stay out of the shopping malls
hang David wait a second you don't get
to hang up yet that's too juicy but wait
a minute he knows the answer David you
know the
answer well what's your recommendation
do I just not bring as much cash into a
Walmart or a shopping mall or do I not
go at all do I uh we're going to dig
deep and find out how deep it is before
you dig I want to also just make
connection with David I suffer from
emotional spontaneous eating so I what
type of things do you eat Ken oh boy uh
chips and salsa okay I go the salty
variety I don't want to make this about
me D in good I want to learn I'm going
to see if what you say to him about
emotional spending I want to know what
it look me with with emotional eating I
want to know David what is the spending
look like are we talking about hey I go
to Target and next thing I know I've
spent $500 on a credit card is it I come
back because it's the Lexus Christmas to
remember and I bought my wife a new car
like how deep does this go I walk into a
shopping mall with say $400 my intention
is to buy one item and leave but you
know how a shopping mall is the next
thing you know you see this you want
that you may be with a woman she sees
this you want that she wants this and
the next thing you know that 400 is gone
I I I I totally get it but here's the
thing you came with 400 this this is
did you go with $400 and you only spent
$400 or did you go with $400 and you
spent far more than
$400 okay that's that's a good I didn't
think about all that I see what you're
saying do you see what I'm saying
because there's part the answer there's
you actually asked a question be both at
any given moment I mean it depends I
mean not that I go to the mall a lot but
you know if you go over the $400 the
extra money that you're spending is this
you putting it on a credit
card yes okay here's what I would
recommend
in general I think that we all can can
be emotional Spenders celebratory
Spenders I'm sad Spenders whatever that
thing that provokes you um I'm a
celebratory spender and eater by the way
um so knowing what those things are like
some of us it's like I like spending
money and these are my SP like it seems
like you have identified the mall is it
for other people it might be HomeGoods
for other people it might be um I don't
know whatever you know Bass Pro Shops
whatever it is right so some of us know
the key area is like if I go in that
store I will buy something so I would
avoid those stores also there's some
data out I just read this don't go
shopping when you're in a sad or mad
state of mind uh there's actually yeah
like it's people go out and and you
don't even have to be in the mall to
want to go buy something when you're sad
or mad that's right so that's that's the
other part so the first part is
identifying what is the store that just
I can't leave without spending something
and then the other part is identifying
what type of spender am I like I said
I'm a celebratory spender I get that I'm
a celebratory eater I get that you David
need to look and go what is the emotion
I'm feeling when I feel the need to
spend so that's number two now
practically speaking this is just me
when whenever somebody says hey Jade I
can't stick to my budget or hey Jade I'm
spending like crazy you what I just tell
people I'm like you need to take the C
the plastic out of your wallet and that
comes in two parts number one if you
have credit cards you need to cut those
Jokers up never to be seen again
and your debit card also needs to come
out of your wallet and you need to
replace that with a stash envelope of
cash that only gets you what you need so
David you're not the guy who needs to
keep $400 of cash in your wallet in of
itself you probably need to keep 25 or
50 and that gets you through the day
don't take a woman to the mall with you
I know that's right I got to add that
don't take these women out you can tell
he's got an issue with this David you
take a lady of the mall what happens to
you
pal I
overspend he over spins he gets soft
like butter he's like I got to spin
she's just because she's looking at
something and you want to make her feel
special David that's correct that's
correct you need to tell her ahead of
time like Jade's advice show her the
envelope and say I only have $50 in this
cuz this other lady in my life named
Jade said I could only have 50 maybe
don't show her the envelope cuz we don't
want her thinking that will take care of
the lady problem yeah it will that's
what I'm doing for him I'm helping him
out David's got a lady problem he does
he does but maybe don't show her $50 and
say this is all the money I have you
find out yes I would that might make the
pool shrink real quick no it'll tell you
whether or not she likes you for you or
the stuff you're getting her David true
I know what I'm talking about women
exactly because everybody has emot now
oh no this is not on I'm not blaming
women I'm blaming you and your weakness
for
women okay well it happens it's right I
didn't get this cardigan you know
without some experience I know what I'm
talking about here you got to be careful
that's your Kryptonite that's you you're
laying it out there 100% are you let me
just go one one tab deeper do you think
that the majority of the spending that
you do is on other other people or other
women or is the majority of the problem
that you're spending on things that
you're buying for yourself 50 50 it's
50/50 so what I would say is Reser like
if you're dating around like if you're
you know swiping left or swiping right
and you're you know going out with
different ladies what is that a dating
app oh okay gotcha Tinder or whatever
whatever the dating app are I'm not
either but I I got my ear to the
pavement Ken so I know what's going on
you are up to date if you're dating
don't spend like big bucks on these like
just a weekend date once you find a lady
and it's like this is my lady then you
can start creating like a a large ler
budget for what you might want to spend
to wine and Diner do you have
debt I have uh about uh I'm about 100 in
credit card Deb oh no that's another
conversation dve 100,000 you didn't tell
us about that no 100 oh okay just
$100 that's nothing okay yeah so we're
paying that off yeah it just made look
I'm telling you the envelope I like you
this is how much I like you on this day
mhm set yourself a clear budget get the
envelope clear amount of money in there
this is for dinner we're not hitting the
mall afterwards it's for dinner in a
movie we're keeping it simple we're not
going to extremes kin no no concessions
at the movie but ladies okay it's poll
time no ant pretzel in the mall James
it's poll time if you're a lady and you
go on a date and he shows you a $50
envelope and says this is it this is all
I got turn on or turn off you tell us is
this a good thing are you like this is a
responsible male or is this a bad thing
I think it depends on how he looks I
really do CA that would give if the guy
showed me a $50 envelope and said this
is it it would give me Uncle boo boo
Vibes and I would be like I don't know
about this guy I just he can keep it a
secret is all I'm saying just take me
out you don't have to tell me everything
right now all right that's fair put it
in the poll let's see what maybe not the
best procedure but a great principal
I'll give you that this is the ramsy
[Music]
show
[Applause]
[Music]
you're listening to the Ramsey Show I am
Jade warshaw you are king Coleman and we
are your co-host together today give us
a call the number is
88255 225 we'd be happy to take your
call um now our question of the day is
brought to you by neighborly neighborly
is your hub for Home Services when you
need to make repairs schedule routine
maintenance or get local help for Home
Improvement projects go to neighbor.com
Ramsey your source to find and schedule
reliable home service providers in your
area today's question comes from Derek
in Oregon what do I do with the leftover
money at the end of the month when I'm
budgeting in every dollar what say you
judge Jade I say you follow those baby
steps uh Derek and whatever baby step
you're on that's where the margin goes
um and that could be anything and for
anybody who's listening for the first
time I'd be happy to just walk you
through those baby steps so you know
where your money you can assess your own
personal situation and go okay where
does my margin go um baby step one is
$1,000 saved if you are in debt and
you're looking for a way out baby step
one you just get $1,000 starter keyword
starter emergency fund then after you've
done that and by the way for your
starter emergency fund you pull that
from any money you might have had before
or you go out and get it you work the
average person is able to get that money
in about 30 days then you move on to
baby step two baby step two is paying
off all of your debt except your
mortgage now this is where we're going
intense and if you have again if you
have a stash of money maybe you got 20K
in the bank you've got money in stocks
that's non-retirement money you take all
that money plus the margin in your
budget you throw it at your debts from
smallest to largest that's called the
debt snowball and that is baby step two
then after that we head on over to baby
step three this is where we're stacking
up 3 to 6 months of an emergency fund F
so if you're listening and you're like
Jade I don't have debt I mean I've got
my mortgage but that doesn't count okay
now you're on baby step three that's
where your margin and your budget goes
to baby step three stacking up 3 to six
months of basic expenses it doesn't have
to be your full-fledged full budget with
all the bells and whistles okay and
after you've done that if you're like
okay I still got some margin we're
investing 15% which happens to be baby
step 4 and we still have some money left
over now you can throw that towards a
529 for your kids you can throw extra
towards your mortgage okay and that's
where that margin goes if you're on baby
steps four five and six your margin is
paying 15% to retirement anything after
that you're putting towards your kids's
College it's not a particular amount
whatever you can get and then whatever
is extra after that you're paying off
your house early and that's how this
thing works and I can't say it enough
when it comes to budgeting I'm going to
call myself out here Ken and you can
tell me what you think okay I'll call
you out I used to think that a budget
was simply a list of your debts and as
long as your money is paying for your
debts and you know what your debts are
and your month-to-month bills car notes
uh hair appoint you know uh those things
that are mandatory car notes rent um
Insurance cell phone as long as you've
paid for that in your budget you're fine
and everything else is just up for grabs
everything else is tree a grab bag if
you want it's a grab bag you don't have
to budget that money yeah no that is not
a budget as I understand it's not a
budget a true budget is a zerob based
budget meaning you take your paycheck
and you give an assignment and you get
to choose some of the things are
mandatory and like this is I'm a
responsible adult I have to pay these
things and then you're also though
assigning that other half that used to
be the treos self money you're giving
that money an assignment too and it's
okay if one of the assignments is hair
appointment it's okay if one of the
assignments is you better believe I have
to get my hairs did you got to get those
hairs did K you know you know John
Maxwell once said that a budget is
telling your money what to do right and
I think that is a very simplistic but
powerful way of looking at the process
of budgeting uh yes zero base because
I've told every dollar where it's going
that's right why we have the every
dollar budgeting app that's why it's
called every dollar you tell every
dollar where to go and by the way I talk
specifically about every dollar in this
new little quick read that just came out
today it's called money's not a math
problem and I call it money is not a
math problem because we're dealing with
things that happen in your mind when it
comes to money but the other play on
this is I'm talking about budgeting and
I'm talking about every dollar and every
dollar does all the math for you so
again it doesn't have to be your math
problem let every dollar figure out that
math problem for you okay Ken Coleman I
see what you did there yeah that's a
seamless self-promo very good I will
beat that drum all right let's go into
the phone lines we got Robert from Las
Vegas Nevada what's going on Robert
hi uh thank you for taking a call um I
have a question um bought a house year
and a half ago firsttime buyer and I'm
late in my life and I would like to try
and pay off the house much earlier than
the 30-year typical 30-year mortgage
yeah so I'm thinking I'm thinking five
to six years maybe Seven Years love that
and so I can so I can enjoy the the the
the house yeah I love that idea I don't
think I'll be around 30 more years to
enjoy it after I retire sure um well I
mean I hope that you have a long full
life but I get this feeling of wanting
to pay off your house I love that my
only question to you would be to make
sure you're at the right point in your
financial journey to actually start
taking those steps so let's dig a little
bit deeper is that cool with
you again okay so we just walk through
those baby steps here a minute ago what
baby step would you be on do you have
debt do you have money
saved I don't have any debt except for
the mortgage and one car payment okay no
credit cards um I've got I've got some
cash yeah how much cash um 35,000 okay
would you call that about how many
months of savings would you say that is
is that three months is it four months
six months no it's right around five
fiveth about five months all right so I
got to jump in because we got the car
payment you said we have no debt except
but the car payment is debt so how much
do you owe on the
car um
wow good question um I don't know the
amount I owe but it's a monthly payment
of 350 and it's only because I got in a
car accident that totaled my almost paid
off car if you had to guess what you
spent on the car what do you think you
what do you think you spend is it 20,000
is it
40,000 oh no no no it's probably more
like 15,000 okay so Ken I'm glad Ken dug
deeper on that I would take some of the
money out of that saving stash that you
have enough to pay off that car
completely and I would get that debt out
of your life cuz it's draining 30 you
know 350 bucks a month from you that you
could be using to pay off your house so
I would pay I would pay that debt off
get it out of your life today today then
you know you've got five months if you
wanted to build that savings back up you
could or if you're like look I'm fine I
you know if that brought you down to
three months and you were fine with
having three months of savings we
suggest 3 to six months so if you want
five again you could take some time and
build it back up and then my next
question to you would be are you
investing 15% of your
income in retirement no I do not have I
do not have any retirement yet it just
got this better income a couple years
ago and we're able to buy the house like
I said about a year and a half ago and
so basically my my plan is to pay the
regular mortgage and then throw a lot of
extra cash at the mortgage for the next
5 to six years I know you want to do
that but I also want to make sure you
you've got plenty of retirement and cash
on hand as well so what I would love to
see you do is also start investing 15%
in you know you've got this new job this
new income I want you investing 15% of
your gross salary and I want you doing
that every month so that you can start
having compound interest work for you so
that when you do you know go on down the
line this money is there and then after
that when you've got that extra money
now you can start putting some extra on
your mortgage however much you can or
however much you'd like to do not have
to be intense about this but I do want
you to be very very intentional about
getting this mortgage paid off and these
all work together I think right now
you're just one track mind I got to do
the mortgage got to do the mortgage
because you want that piece right I
think everybody wants the feeling of not
owing anybody anything but there's
methods to Madness yeah there was a plan
for the retirement it was like five
years towards the house and then the
next five years would be just all
towards retirement yeah since I wouldn't
have any major debt look look look
Robert at the end of the day you can
work your plan if you want to I'm not
mad at you you're grown man if you want
to work the plan that you had and that
you created you are free and clear to do
that but if you call us we're going to
tell you what our plan was and what our
plan is and the plan that's worked for
millions and millions of people a plan
that's been around for over 30 years so
it's your Prerogative Bobby Brown said
you can do what you want to do but I'm
going to tell you what Ramsey solution
says so it's your world this is the
Ramsey
Show
[Music]
yeah
this is the ramsy show I am Jade warshaw
one of your hosts for today I'm joined
by Ken Coleman your other host for the
day Ken it's fun to host with you it's
fun to take calls if you're interested
in calling us and getting our take on
your life your money your career
whatever is going on with you you can
give us a call the number is 8825 5225
and it would be really our great honor
to just discuss that with you absolutely
so the phone lines are open we've got
Elizabeth who's in Charlotte North
Carolina what's going on
Elizabeth hey there how are you guys
doing good how are
you I'm doing well thank you for taking
my call um I'll get straight to the
point um I'm newly divorced and I have
three children that I'm taking care of
alone now
um one has autism I have two
Embraces W um and I my question is is
I'm caught up in a cycle of payday loans
I just started listening to your show
last week so my normal job I'm working
five nights a week as a nurse and so now
that I've heard your show I have now
picked up every day that I have off I
shift or or doubles um so pretty much um
the reason I can't work anymore is
because I don't I only have a sitter at
night so I have to do what I can when I
can but I've got to get out of this debt
um how much do you make before you get
into
overtime um about 76,000 and what do you
think this overtime I know you're brand
new to this but what do you think the
overtime is going to make you in a given
month if you're able to keep up the
schedule um probably an extra 2,000 per
month per month yeah okay all right so
at this point I just want to make sure
for clarity at this point you're five
nights a week or at this point are you
seven nights a week um I just picked up
put it this way last week I heard your
show I was doing five nights a week now
I'm doing every night a week okay now
you're doing every night a week okay
very very cool um so tell me more about
this payday lender and tell me more
about the
debt um okay I have a car 24,000 I have
about 15,000 in credit card and then I
have probably two personal loans that's
about um 5,000 together okay um like I
said I'm paying for two sets of braces
um one child has been through like three
you know how you start all over you take
them off and then they put them on to do
something different do I oh so what are
the What's the total debts on that
combined um right now I only owe about
$250 more dollars on the braces but I
think they're going to start over with
something else with one of them one of
the kid and that'll be probably another
5,000 and do you have to do that okay
we'll talk about that in a minute what
else do you have I got expertise on that
issue tap me when you're ready I will
tap you in Ken what else do you have um
elizabe let's see um other than the
payday loans I just have rent because um
I don't have of course I'm not buying
now I have a rent of like 2,000 rent is
2,000 okay um how much are the payday
loans you didn't tell
me oh the payday loans together I could
probably pay them off with 3,000 3,000
how many of them is it it's four okay so
four payday loans equaling 3,000 okay um
do some quick math for me after your
taxes after everything like that with
your overtime what are you bringing home
taking home per
month um I haven't gotten my first check
with the overtime yet but I'm pretty
sure it'll be close to seven 7,000 good
job Mama yeah M good job uh okay so are
you on a budget because me talking about
this means nothing if you're not on a
budget you know what I just I haven't I
I just got everything written down um
but my thing is now I had to break bad
news to everybody that we're not buying
anything for anything I know that's
right you know I'm dealing with the
pouting but I'm like whatever y'all
gonna get they get they'll get through
it this is gonna be temporary this is
going to be a temporary sacrifice to win
before you leave Austin's going to give
you every dollar because I want you on a
budget that is going to make this as
easy as possible for you okay because on
every dollar you're going to put
everything in there and you're going to
really be able to see at the end of the
rent at the end of the bills at the end
of everything what is my margin to
actually be able to start paying off
some of this debt and first things first
um Elizabeth I want to give you a little
bit of breathing room do you have any
money
saved I have not one dime because I've
been putting everything trying to catch
my bill I've never been behind my bills
and now with all this happing all my
bills are behind and I'm like I can't it
fre feel like you're freaking out yeah I
want you to tonight cuz you're going to
get the every dollar budget after this
call tonight I want you to work on that
that in between your shifts on your
break CU I know you're working tonight I
want you to get this every dollar budget
up and running because when you see the
numbers you're going to get some peace
just knowing what the situation is for
real for real is going to give you peace
and first things first I know you want
to get these bills I want you to get
quickly a thousand dollar saved that's
right and when I and you're probably
like Jade you just add $ thousand dollar
to my plate sell
something go through these kids rooms
look at these TVs sell this stuff and
get you $1,000 doll and you let me tell
you what what that's going to do for you
Elizabeth you are going to be ahead just
by doing that of the majority of
Americans and I know you don't you may
be the majority of Americans can't cover
a thousand emergency in cash
so just having that you're going to go
okay winning at life and then you're
going to move on and you're going to
start going through these debts one by
one you're going to list them smallest
to largest so it sounds like the uh
either the braces is going to be first
or one of these payday loans is going to
be first and with all this extra
overtime you are going to knock these
bad boys out with I you're coming at
them with a club like with a
sledgehammer you're knocking these
things out going as quickly as possible
I love that you already told the kids
we're not doing it when it comes to
Christmas I ain't got no money right
we're not doing that okay and then I
wanted to take a serious look at this
car okay if you I've already thought
about selling it okay what could it go
for um what I've been seeing well this I
probably could get 22 to 23 for it okay
so a th000 bucks upside down upside
down yeah okay so what you could do you
could go over to to a little Credit
Union and see if they'll give you a loan
for the the ,000 plus a couple of other
thousand so you can get you a cash car
so essentially you're going from 24
$25,000 in debt to5 or $6,000 in debt
you could do that since you're a little
upside down and that would get you out
instantly go to a little Credit Union
don't fool with Sofi and some of these
other Jokers make sure you get a person
that you're talking to and you're saying
look this is my situation okay so you
could look into that but this is you
know you got a little bit of a journey
in front of you and you're going to walk
it do you feel like you have the
tools I I I'm I put it this way I'm
motivated very motiv very motivated love
it well let me let me say this Elizabeth
you're actually okay um you I know what
you're feeling and I'm glad you feel
this way because it's it's got you awake
and it's got you motivated but I also
want to encourage you I don't want you
losing sleep tonight um you're going to
be able to come up with $1,000 for that
baby that first baby step emergency fund
pretty quickly okay and the amount of
money you're bringing home right now if
you budget if you do what Jade tells you
she's going to give you all kinds of
great goodies and but if you actually
get a hold of the 7,000 take home based
even on that car payment you're okay
you're you're not you're okay if you
actually just get control of the money
and go all right Beyond giving the
speech to the kids which is the first
step yeah but I will say you're okay I
Want You to Breathe easier in
yes uh wary worried about the situation
youve put yourself in sure a little bit
but you're going to be okay and so get
that $1,000 first then work your way
through the baby steps uh and you'll
knock that car out uh you'll be fine or
you can pay the car down then sell it
when you got more margin in the car but
you've got breathing room I want to make
sure if you keep this overtime up and
you get in the budget you've got room in
that budget to where you're not going to
be panicked you're going to be out of
this debt quicker than you realize
that's right that's what I want you to
hear never ever ever ever ever set foot
in a payday loan store ever again now
let me also say on the braces cuz I want
to get practical I I listen I have three
kids all three have had braces the
multiple times too here's what I'm going
to tell you I'd be on the phone with the
orthodontist and go give me the real
reel yeah do we need we month can we
wait 12 minutes remember you're in
charge of the kids's teeth not the
orthodontist right and unless something
bad is happening it's going to cause
issues down the road like for real
issues press pause uh we did that I had
to cash flow three sets of braces plus
my wife braces plus retainers uh and we
did it when we could do it and by the
way the kids teeth are fine so I'd press
pause on that if you can this is the
ramsy
[Music]
show
you're listening to the ramsy show
thanks for listening our scripture and
quote of the day for I know the plans I
have for you declares the Lord plans to
prosper you and not to harm you plans to
give you hope and a future that's
Jeremiah 2911 one of my favorites and
Babe Ruth said this he said it's hard to
beat a person who never gives up love
that love it love it love it hey give us
a call the number Isle 8825
5225 uh we want to talk to you we want
to know what's going on in your life and
we will help you as best as we can uh
talking about myself and Ken Coleman
over here to my right let's go to the
phone lines Ken we've got Porsha who's
in Dallas Texas what's going on
Porsha hi thank you all so much for
taking my call you're welcome I want to
I am extremely extremely stressed out
right now um it's mostly because I'm in
kind of like stuck in between a rock and
a hard place right now okay I am having
the I want to finish my nurs
program um at school but I'm also in a
lot of Debs and I have six babies um
that you know I home yes I am married my
husband does have and I do also have two
bonus babies so total we total have who
are the bonus babies tell me about these
bonus
babies so when I got married um I had
five he had three we had a daughter last
year and so we technically we have we
have nine all oh my word what is the uh
range of Ages wow sorry I have boys who
are both of us have boys who are now 17
both are graduating next year okay um I
have a daughter 16 all the way down to a
daughter that's one okay oh so you're
just
exhausted wow yes so wow I have recently
um pretty much argued my whole entire
family down why I work full-time let's
go there and I pretty much recently
argued my whole family down that I can
continue working and going to school at
night and in a hassle now to add all of
that you know in full to injury but I
also pay out a pocket for my schooling
which is roughly around 2,600 a month
wow okay um yeah and so right now I paid
the first payment of course and I'm
continuing to go to school um not only
that but I have to we pay daycare we
also pay someone to help out with
children right on Wednesday Thursday
Saturdays while I'm at school yes and
so yeah and I'm just is the problem the
money or you're at is the problem the
money or you're at your wt's end um the
problem is the money and I'm at my
witsend because I'm not sure if I should
continue to pay out of pocket for my
schooling because I feel like this will
put me in a better position or if I
should try to pay off Deb okay so let's
get a quick snapshot of of the finance
part because you've already said you
talked your family down which tells me
the family's going we need you at home
is that is that fair okay well the kids
are like Mom we support you we got it my
husband's like you have a lot on your
plate and a lot of family is like a
portion you know that's right to do it
but this you do all right so what's the
financial picture how much debt do you
guys
have so myself I am I mean it's gonna be
around maybe 80,000 and that's me being
very modest no no ma'am that's student
loans is 73,000 okay I can't get student
loans or anything anymore so I've been
paying out of pocket to finish my degree
okay so 73,000 in student loans 880,000
in other types of debt what are the
other what does that 880,000 consist no
no no no no no no you said 880,000 total
for you correct no well it's so total
it's 175 and this is just for me I'm
gonna be completely honest with you my
husband didn't have any debt but his car
broke down recently my vehicle was
stolen his car broke down and so he has
to get another car which I mean it's
$1,000 a month total for the insurance
and the car all right so slow down for a
second because we're going to help you
but we got to you got
175,000 in debt I don't care who it's
our debt okay so 175 total is what
you're dealing with with debt correct
yes for the entire household are you
guys with your full-time job and your
husband's full-time job and you paying
2600 00 a month in nursing school um are
you guys paycheck to paycheck are you
are you not having any money left over
at the end of the month what's that look
like yes it it's pretty much paycheck to
paycheck I was doing a lot of overtime
to uh kind of make you know ends meet
and then pay for school one other quick
question one other quick question uh
Jay's gonna help you on all this but I'm
trying to gather info quick okay because
we don't have a lot of time we got four
minutes all right so we got to help all
right
um how much nursing school do you have
left how much before you would finish
the
program two years all right and then
what would your increased income be what
are you projecting if you were to finish
nursing how much more could you
make at minimum 880,000 I'm currently at
54 okay all right so all right Jade I
just wanted to try to gather really
quick and hand it to you but I will tell
you I I want her pressing pause on
nursing school nursing school will still
be there so she's going from 504 80 not
increasing 80,000 that's correct but
she's got two years left so what's the I
want to know combined income what money
do you guys see monthly in your hand
every single
month uh so I make 54 he makes 60 okay
so have a calculator yeah okay 54 and 60
is that after tax is that pre like I
just want to know in your hand when you
when y'all get your two checks what do
you get for the
month oh um give me one second well
looking at we're probably both looking
around we're probably looking at 88,000
a month together okay I love that now
what I want to call out here is you've
got to know your numbers when people
call in here the first symptom of I that
I see of just pure chaos is when
somebody can't tell me what they earn
every month and I'm not trying to call
you out but what I do want to call out
is money is expensive the money that you
earn is expensive Porsche it is costing
you your time away from your kids it is
costing you your sanity it is costing
you your sleep these dollars you make
are expensive let's treat them with care
and like they are worth what we give to
them fair right all right that is fair
it's fair cuz girl you are getting it
you are working hard but they're also in
Big Time debt and you're in big time
debt so I want you to know go home and
get your numbers I want you on an every
dooll budget okay you're going to plug
in this income and you are going to know
your numbers and then you're going to
start working down that list you're
going to say okay we got $88,000 or
$8,700 whatever it is and you're going
to go line by line and say okay first
things first you know groceries and
you're going to go through the most
important items rent first food
utilities Transportation that's the
first most important stuff get your
giving in there and you're going to go
line by line and then you're going to
see okay what's left after all those
important things are done what do we
have left that's called margin and with
the margin we're going to go through and
that's when we're going to decide okay
School versus debt Ken Coleman said I
think you should hold off on the school
well which Finds Me 2 $600 it's a lot
that's what I'm saying toward I agree
with you I agree I think that you could
essentially guys put the pedal to the
metal and with your income you might
have the ability to pay this off in the
next two to three years and then you're
going to have this complete freedom to
really go out and pay cash for the
things that you want to do you'll be
able to really truly focus on school how
old are you I am 35 and I am having a
hard time focusing on school because of
everything else that I have going on
100% 100% that's not fair to you by the
way yeah it's not fair to you so take
care of you you and hubs get together
and fix this this is going to be a two
to threee gut busting slog like get
after it to get this debt out of your
life and then here's the good news you
get through the nursing school with no
stress you're going to get a nice chunk
of change I want to throw one other
thing out here but it's not for now but
it may be for maybe a year from now Jade
get it I would like for you to to just
dig around talk to people you're in the
know you're going to nursy school be
interested to see if there's any
hospital or clinics or anybody that be
willing to reimburse you for your
schooling because if if we could if now
I still would press pause to get life
under control and budgeting and be a
mama and all that but maybe six months
to a year from now you get a little bit
of margin if you could get that
reimbursed or someone pay for your
nursing because right now in America all
over this country we have a a a need for
nurses they're quitting their burning
out at a very high rate not to freak you
out just keeping it real here but if
you're committed to it I would like to
see her potentially see could she get
that nursing reimbursed or paid for I
like that I think there's after she does
what you tell her to do yeah I think
there's a good chance of that look she's
got this woman is a superwoman nine
babies she's taking care of going to
nursing school working it doesn't get
any crazier than that I'm proud of her
abolutely and I know that they can get
through this debt if they work together
woo Ken that was a great 3 hours buddy I
need to take a nap after that last call
look let me tell you something when it
comes to your life and money you can
tell me that you won't do it but never
tell me that you can't With God all
things are possible this is the ramsy
[Music]
show
a